d'abord permettez-moi de me présenter je
l'appelle travis et je suis le fondateur
et le pdg de hubert
je suis un [ __ ] de billets de loterie
pour ceux qui en veulent dans la vie
dont le bad boy le plus célèbre de la
technologie on est l'une des plus
grandes appli de tous les temps ensemble
on continuera de conquérir le monde
entier sont égaux commence à poser
problème il a besoin d'être canalisé bon
joseph gordon-levitt dans la cour du
fondateur de tumeurs vous voulez
travailler pour google
est ce que vous êtes un trou du cul
notre nouvelle série super forme ce
battle for ever à partir du jeudi 2 juin
seulement sur canal+